pause the video and read this problem
well
it says that in a particular class 85
kids play football 70 to play cricket
and 43 play tennis and the entire
problem talks about these three spots
some kids play too and some play all
three spots and each kid plays at least
one of the sports the fact that three
spots are involved implies that it is a
three set Venn diagram and with this
information we have been asked to find
these three things the first thing we've
been asked is for the total number of
kids we have been told that 85 play
football 70 to play cricket and 43 play
tennis so the total number of kids in
the class will be 85 plus 72 plus 43
that is 200 there are 200 students in
this class and this is a classic mistake
that is made the best way to approach
such problems is to draw the Venn
diagrams first and then answer the
questions the question is how do we draw
the Venn diagram how many circles will
they intersect okay
let's go through the question again the
first line tells us that the problem is
about three sports football cricket and
tennis so there will be three circles
one for each spot 44 play football and
cricket so there is definitely an
intersection between their circles we
can draw a circle for F and a circle for
C like this this is the intersection
part which has 44 kids look at the last
line there are four kids that play all
three sports the circle for tennis will
look a bit like this 15 play both
cricket and tennis this is that
intersection 25 play both football and
tennis this is that intersection and
this region in between has the four kids
that play all three sports there is
another thing you should keep in mind
while solving three set when diagrams
always start in the center and go
outwards the region in the center
consists of the student that play all
three sports and that number is 4 so
right a foreign here now going outwards
we target these three regions forty-four
play both football and cricket so this
entire intersection is forty four and
out of that forty four this region has
four kids so the remaining 40 will be in
this region so the total is 44 out of
the forty four four play all three and
the remaining 40 play just football and
cricket with the same logic try filling
in the numbers in these two regions now
15 play both cricket and tennis so if
this entire region is 15 and four play
all three then this region will have
eleven students 11 plus 4 is 15 15 play
both cricket and tennis next we know
that 25 play both football and tennis so
this region will have 21 kids 21 plus 4
is 25 so the three outer regions are
remaining now kids that play only
football only cricket and only tennis 85
kids play football
so this entire circle is 85 and out of
the 85 these three sub regions cover 40
plus 25 65 kids so we can say that 20
kids play only football
now you try filling in the numbers in
these two regions 70 to play cricket so
72 minus 40 minus 4 minus 11 will give
us the number that play only cricket
that's 17 17 kids play only cricket and
43 play tennis this full circle will
have 43 kids and 43 minus 21 minus 4
minus 11 is equal to 7 now our Venn
diagram is ready with all regions filled
in now let's tackle the first question
what is the total number of students
equal to 2 find the total we just add up
all these numbers 20 plus 40
60 plus 25 is 85 85 plus 7 is 92 92 plus
11 is 103 and 103 plus 17 is 120 120 is
the total number of kids in this class
next we have been asked the number of
kids that play cricket and tennis but
not football cricket and tennis is this
intersection and if we have to exclude
football we cannot consider these four
kids that play football as well it will
just be 11 the answer to Question B is
11 11 kids play cricket and tennis but
not football and the last question is
the number of kids that play only
football we can clearly see that 20 kids
play only football the answer to
Question C is 20 20 of them play only
football so 3 set Venn diagram problems
are really easy provided we are able to
draw it correctly and don't forget
always move outwards